our purpose is to mine copper
efficiently unsustainable sustainably
you know with the purpose of you know
providing the needs of a greener modern
economy and and the link with our title
sponsorship in the case of formula II is
signaling exactly that I think the way
mining is done today in the in the sense
the engagement that we have with
communities the way that we protect the
environment and mitigate the impacts
that we have talk of a different way of
doing mining and and I think what's also
very important is to really realize the
value that copper and other minerals
make enabling the modern economy as we
we we know it today so formulary you've
even asked this picked on the average
typical Formula e car goes from nought
to 100 in three seconds which is fast
but not as fast as Formula one how
exciting is it a proposition for the
fans oh I think it's very exciting and
and you know this is it's a signal of
how the economy modern economy is
changing moving from internal combustion
engines to electrical cars it's a whole
revolution and the technology is still
evolving in formulary there is a
mandatory pit stop while the drivers
change vehicles doesn't that show the
limitations of electric cars well I
think as I say the technology is still
evolving I think the main issue with
electrical cars is still the level of
autonomy and and today however you know
they're more advanced electrical
vehicles have autonomous which exceed
the 200 you know miles distance and that
is growing and I think technology's
changing extremely fast so you'll be
surprised and I'll be surprised as well
how fast you know the autonomy of these
cars will start increasing and I think
what's important is that formula is also
stretching the boundaries of the
technology and pushing it you know to
its limits so it's also helping you know
to further the advance in autonomous
cars and electrical cars which is what
the future is all about
now the rise of electrical cars is
leading to it's obviously spurring
demand for copper but also other metals
particularly lithium on the metal
exchange talking about launching the
lithium contract it's the market itself
capable
of meeting this new demand I think I
think it is I mean the certainly for
copper it's a it's a great story the the
demand for copper is very much linked to
what's happening in emerging economies
mostly China in terms of infrastructure
growth and in other sectors but there's
been a big revolution with the emergence
of electrical transport and you know
electrical mobility and we have still
yet to fully understand the numbers but
an electrical car carries around four or
five times more copper than a
conventional car so the impact is quite
significant it's interesting to notice
for example that today they're around 3
million electrical cars which are sold
every year and this is between hybrid
and battery electrical cars and that is
expected by analysts to move to around
10 times that so you know a significant
increase by 2030 so a few years from now
it'll be 30 million cars that will be
sold so the change that's happening is
very significant and I think that you
know brings well for copper and I think
the industry obviously you know has to
respond to that and and what we're
seeing is that you know prices are
responding you know to to the increased
demand and you're over in London of
course for LME week this is where the
great and the good of the global metals
industry get together what's the mood
like right now I think the mood is is
certainly more positive than what it was
a year or two ago I think people are
seeing that we're coming out of downturn
which saw prices drop to around $2 you
know per pound of copper and we are
certainly you know above those numbers
so I think the mood is is positive but I
think generally you know people are
being cautiously optimistic you know the
the the trend is favourable I think
longer-term the fundamentals are strong
for copper but there's bound to be
volatility in the short term